dans un imposant article publié le 13
avril le new york times évoque une
présumée campagne de fausses
informations
le journal new yorkais accuse la russie
et son président de désinformation
sanitaire une décennie de désinformation
sanitaire promue par le président russe
vladimir poutine a sommé une grande
confusion porter préjudice aux grandes
institutions et encourager la
propagation de maladies mortelles selon
le new york times
vladimir poutine a joué un rôle majeur
dans la diffusion de fausses
informations dans le cadre de son effort
général pour discréditer l'occident et
détruire ses ennemis de l'intérieur
le quotidien cite notamment l'auteur
peter pomerantz f
selon qui il s'agit de semer un manque
de confiance dans les institutions
gouvernementales
william jim rhodes l'auteur de l'article
usant suite de nombreux prétendu exemple
évoquant à plusieurs reprises des trolls
russe qui propageraient de fausses
informations
le président russe a mené sa longue
campagne par le biais de médias ou vert
de trolls secrets et de blogs obscures
qui présente régulièrement les
responsables américains de la santé
comme des escrocs l'ancien président
barack obama a pour sa part relayé
l'article sur twitter la démocratie
dépend d'une citoyenneté informé de la
cohésion sociale
voici un aperçu de la manière dans la
désinformation peut se propager par le
biais des réseaux sociaux
et pourquoi elle peut nuire à notre
capacité à répondre aux crises un
article qui a provoqué l'ire des
autorités russes à commencer par
l'ambassade de russie aux états unis
monsieur obama a appris qu'il était
passé à côté de beaucoup de choses
pendant son mandat de président des
états unis
pourquoi n'at-il pas réagi très simple
il n'y a pas eu d'ingérence russe ni de
campagne de désinformation
juste une nouvelle publication de
mauvaise qualité
même son cloche du côté de maria
zakharova porte parole de la diplomatie
russe
le secrétaire d'état américain a menacé
de traduire en justice tous les
complices de désinformation sur la
pandémie
commencez donc par le new york times
l'article la longue guerre de poutine
contre la science américaine est un
chef-d'oeuvre de désinformation c'est
pourtant dans un contexte d'accalmie
entre américains et russes que surgit
cet article le président poutine estime
que la pandémie est le moment où il faut
s'entraider a déclaré à la presse le
porte parole du crime
l'un dimitri peskov qualifiant également
de très positive la proposition de
donald trump d'envoyer des respirateurs
artificiels en russie